it's Christmastime in Florida a time
when neighbors get together to share
some holiday cheer but at this Christmas
party
some might say they share too much
Marian Higgins doesn't worry that her
guests are stripping all the way down
in fact she encourages it furs are often
comfortable like most of them Marian
lives here because she doesn't want to
wear clothes and she doesn't expect
others to wear them either I live nude I
sleep nude I go to the restaurant I go
visiting those neighbors my friends
whatever I do in this community is nude
Marian lives in Lake Como a place where
clothing isn't just optional it's
actually discouraged Lake Como is one of
more than 250 private clubs in North
America where nudists can enjoy their
favorite pastimes in their favorite
state buck-naked in some places here
they are even required to but there's
more to it than skinny-dipping any work
that I do I do it's more like a religion
to me more than anything we do our
housework in the nude clean the cars in
the nude we will be nude as often as we
can to enjoy that that activity whatever
activity that is even if that activity
is one few would try even wearing
protective gear I'm hoping to see an
alligator down in this area but if
you're like Gerald Petrov and want to
live your life naked the only way to do
it is to live a life apart in order to
spend their lives without clothes
nudists must form their own communities
and keep them well out of sight
we have 200 acres with swamps forests
surrounding us in areas where we don't
we have a fence to separate us from the
neighbors this isolation works two ways
it protects nude residents from prying
eyes and neighbors from any unwanted
exposure set apart from what they call
the textile world the people of Lake
Como create a tight-knit community of
their own
I think nudist communities are very much
communities almost extended family
everybody tends to know everybody
but like any group of outcasts they're
cautious about outsiders we pay
attention to who we admit we don't want
to admit into our group people that
really are inappropriate voyeurs or or
people that are here for the wrong
reasons we do a criminal background
check on new members as well as a
reference check and if we have any
doubts about them then we don't allow
them admittance newcomers are also
watched closely and schooled in the
taboos unique to this society we teach
them no blocking no inappropriate
behavior and no touching with children
we have a zero tolerance if an adult
spends too much time even talking to two
kids the person is asked to later drinks
cookies bugs right
the people of Lake Como know that their
chances of winning over the textile
world are slim if they just accepted us
for who we are and forget what we're
wearing or not wearing I think that
would be a nicer world but I know
that'll never happen until it does they
are happy finding refuge in their life
apart when my children and my
grandchildren come and we walk around
nude I am so proud i heart sometimes
feels like it's going to burst